unauthorized protests are illegal in
Kazakhstan in the largest city Almaty
police arrested dozens of activists who
were on their way to an anti-government
rally I'm being detained for no reason
they just caught me in the street I'm 66
years old and I have heart problems let
me go Sunday's rallies were organized
following the death of duel at a Goodell
the 42 year old activist died in jail
last Monday he'd been arrested by police
for allegedly insulting a judge the
Kazakh government said he died of heart
failure but activists say the bruises on
his body suggest he was beaten to death
public anger over corruption and
arbitrary detentions has intensified
since Qasim yamato Kiev replaced
Nursultan Nazarbayev as president last
year
Nazarbayev had been in power since 1991
International monitoring group said the
vote was not free or fair opposition
activists say they'll continue to demand
more freedoms who took me in the vehicle
like a dog like cattle even cattle are
treated better than us
we've already turned into cattle worse
than cattle the United States and the
United Kingdom have called for an
investigation into AG Adele's death the
government's crackdown on protesters has
raised more awareness of his case
Victoria gate MB al Jazeera